we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
caller who wants to bet me about
something take a listen to what they
want to bet on hey David
are you wound to bet and this I don't
know if you're a betting man but are you
willing to bet one day that Alexandria
Cascio Cortes will be President I'll put
$20 in the six back on it I'm not um no
that's not I'm not I don't know if he
wants to bet me that she will and I
would bet that she wouldn't or vice
versa but in any case I am not a betting
man and in any case that's not even a
gentlemen's bet that I could take I I
just think it's so early pad to even
start speculating about that I get it
the could the the appeal that she's
having on the basis of charisma and
personality it is something there's no
question about it
but I I'm not ready to make any bets one
way or the other about AOC as a possible
future president well she's only what 28
years old so she'd have to wait until
she was 35 so it would be a while and
even then you'd think that she would
want to wait around until she was in her
40s and 50s and had some experience but
you might as well take the bet because
$20 now that's a little bit of money but
given you know inflation that may just
be peanuts in a couple decades yeah but
that would then I would also be losing
much more than $20 if I lost the bet
right so I don't know that inflation is
uh when I'm thinking about making bets I
usually am not thinking about inflation
but that's an interesting approach well
maybe delve into more about that on the
bonus show today speaking of which we
have a great bonus show today Amazon has
started to test deliveries with sidewalk
drones we follow up about the pregnancy
of a woman in a vegetative state in a US
care home as it's called and we will
also talk about new findings regarding
body size and longevity split among
gender lines very interesting bonus show
today I hope you'll join me there as a
member or as a patron